Let's go to the Friday feed bag. Someone wrote to
me and said, David, instead of feedback Friday.
Or Friday feedback.
You should call it the feed
bag. Like a horse that eats.
Out of a bag. I don't know. Listen, folks, I'm.
Going to go over some messages.
That I received from people.
Significant reaction to the anti-trans explosion
from CPAC over the weekend. One message I received
very much representative of others, Kyle said,
What about all the rights the drag and trans
community is trying to take from all other
people? So. I don't know what the hell Kyle.
Is talking about, and I've heard this before.
That the people's rights are
being taken by the drag and
trans community since Dragon Trans are
two different things. Let's maybe see if.
We can think that through.
I can't even think of any
bad arguments that the drag.
Community is taking anybody's rights.
I know the right might might say, well, they're
taking away parents rights not to be around
drag queens. They're really not. And when you
look at the details of all of these drag time,
story hours and whatever, parents are bringing
their kids to them. So I don't understand how
anybody's losing a right there. If anything,
parents are continuing to have the right to say,
here's what I want to show my kid
or here's what I don't want to.
Show my kid.
Now, as far as the trans community, I think
the argument they love to make is if I quote,
have to call someone by a certain pronoun, then
I've lost my right of free speech. But of course,
that's not really the case. What we're talking
about here is decorum. There are situations where
states might have a law, for example, with
regard to being able to change your driver's
license or at work changing your employee file
if you've transitioned. But these things don't
really have anything to do with rights. And it's
sort of like if you're just out in the world
and you don't want to use someone's preferred
pronouns, it's not a question of rights,
it's just a question of decorum and politeness.
The same way that you could choose to use racist
words around people. It's not a matter of rights,
it's a matter of how are you going to treat
others. So as usual, they talk about free speech.
When it's not a free speech issue, they talk.
About rights when it's not a rights issue.
Okay. A lot of people don't like
my analysis and coverage of Trump
speeches and rallies. Laura wrote to me and
said, You're horrible. It's the wrong your.
Required. It's the wrong your your horrible making
from. Of Trump I assume. I assume Laura means.
Making fun.
Of Trump. You're horrible. My horrible
making frum of Trump the best ever.
Get a life and find another job.
You aren't funny fact worthless.
She adds
My favorite thing I have to. I know that this some
people don't like this. My favorite thing is when.
People hate that this is my.
Job.
And it's a great job to have with tons of great
benefits and perks and the ability to communicate
with great people every day and build a community.
So, you know what, Laura? I think I'm going to.
Keep my job. And if you don't like my thoughts
about Trump speeches, you don't have to watch.
Cooper left a comment. You're free again. It's
the wrong your guys. You're free. Why? Oh,
you are free to do whatever
you want as long as you're.
Prepared wrong your to suffer the consequences.
So keep on doing drag shows for kids
and you'll eventually get what's.
Coming to you.
Is this a threat of violence against the
drag performers? Because who's doing the
drag shows? The drag performers and and what on
earth could possibly be coming to them? They're
not doing anything wrong. Everybody's fine.
I was thinking the other day, talking with.
A friend of mine, you know.
When my daughter is at.
Whatever age she might find it.
And I think of this entertaining, would there be
anything damaging if she saw a drag performer?
And I really couldn't think of anything. It's just
a what? How would that even rank? What how would
that be? Anything to even be remotely concerned
about? So I don't know what the consequences are
going to be, and I don't even know what Cooper
says the consequences are to the people seeing.
The drag shows. It's all wild.
Abortion still an issue.
For many in our audience.
David wrote in, left a comment.
And said, What young people don't
understand is you will reach out to
God on your deathbed. How will you
explain your stance on abortion or
the abortions you had? You will reach
for hope no matter what in the end.
David. I'm ready to make a promise to you today.
I am never, never, never going to feel
the need to explain to anyone the.
Abortions I've had because I'm not
going to be having any. But this.
Is a really common.
Guilt thing.
This is a big I would say this
is a really Christian thing.
Now, many Christians would say that's not that's
not the spirit of Christianity. What I mean is.
A lot of evangelical.
Christians will fearmonger in this way, which is
when the time comes for your ultimate judgment
here on Earth. You're going to repent for
what you did if you chose to have an abortion.
These folks need to move on from
something to something other than
fear. Except the fear works really
well. That's why they keep at it.
US. Many people not liking my Bill Maher
criticisms lately. Sammy wrote in and said, Bro,
bro, you could do better than attacking Bill
Maher. If you don't see Wokeness as a problem,
you're not looking hard enough. While remember.
Even Bill Maher couldn't define wokeness. He
was given the opportunity by Jake TAPPER on
CNN. What do you mean by woke? And he said
something about Abraham Lincoln. Okay. If they
want to actually explain what they mean by woke,
then I'm glad to engage with it in that
way. But that seeing Wokeness as a problem,
I don't even know what you mean by
woke. And most of them don't even.
Know what they mean.
That's been something we've.
Looked at a number of times.
David says The populist left is no better
than the populist right. One tends to lead
to actual communism and the other tends to lead to
actual fascism. Unfortunately, the more centrist.
Positions.
Require a lot more work to maintain. The
leaders of either side have to work harder
to craft something meaningful that the voters
will respond to consistently. And the voters
themselves must work harder to stay accurately
informed about the issues. But that, in essence,
is also the key to a functioning democracy.
Best of luck to us. But the big picture going
forward isn't very promising. Listen, I you
I don't know about populist left leads to.
Actual communism, and I'm not sure about that.
But what I will tell you is
I have called out populist.
Rhetoric on the left and
right for a very long time.
What's my main gripe with populism? It's that
populism is not a policy platform or a set of
policy ideas. Populism is a rhetoric. And as a
rhetoric, it can be used to bamboozle people.
Into all sorts of bad policy.
The example I've used before is,
you know, both Bernie and Tucker will
use populist sounding rhetoric about the.
Abandoned middle class.
Sounds very similar. Tucker's proposal, though, is
we need to do something about Black Lives Matter,
who will take your house and brown
immigrants who will take your job.
Right. That Tucker uses the rhetoric to
suggest those as policies. And so I've
said for a long time we've got to be really
careful about populist rhetoric. Populism,
it's not really a set of policy ideas,
but it is a rhetoric and it can be used
in a lot of horrible ways. Joseph left
a comment on Facebook about the loyalty.
Pledge that Donald Trump is being asked to sign.
Joseph says Trump could very well sign the
pledge. He would want to be on the debate.
He wants the attention.
If he doesn't end up the Republican
candidate, I think he would.
Claim the process.
Was rigged.
In some way.
I think he's determined to be on the
ballot, whether as the Republican candidate.
Or as an independent, if.
He becomes an independent candidate on
the ballot and he comes in third. I think
everyone would finally turn against
him. Even the MAGA freaks will turn.
Their backs on him.
If that happens, maybe Trump.
Will finally fade away.
Yeah, I mean.
Listen, guys.
He's 76. He'll be 78 ish at the time
of the election. I think that if Trump.
Doesn't win the nomination and
or doesn't find a way to win the.
Presidential election, his political.
Career is over. And I know, you
know, a lot of people insist.
Oh, Bernie should run again or
whatever. But Bernie, Bernie's.
Done with running for president. I would bet
money on that. And otherwise, I think Joseph
is absolutely right. Trump will do what he needs
to do to get on the stage. And then that is that.
Bill posted to the subreddit and says,
I don't know if this is a tough, touchy.
Touchy subject in here or not.
But what in the heck.
Is David doing with his.
Mustache? He's my favorite media personality.
But this is getting out of control. He looks
like a teenage dirtbag. It's very off putting.
Is he trolling somebody? I don't understand.
It's awful. He's a very handsome guy when
he's clean shaven. But it's clear whatever
he's doing with his facial hair is 100%
deliberate. So I utterly perplexed by his
choice. I'm sorry, David, but it's one
of the worst mustaches I've ever seen.
It looks terrible. I love this. And
I also love only two thirds of the.
Vote of the audience agrees.
With this.
Take one third does not.
Folks, this is satirical, facial hair,
satirical. Okay, I've even got a mullet
going. It's just a joke. It's satire.
Now I've got the goatee. I'm getting a
haircut. In a couple of days, we're going
to reboot everything. Just relax. I'm glad
it provides entertainment,
but it's really not worth.
Getting so worked up about. But an.
Absolutely genius. If if the message
what I'm wondering is, is this message.
Satire as well?
It's it's awful. One of the worst mustaches.
I've ever seen. I love it.
All right. And then Window Piper via.
Reddit, says David. Don't feed the trolls.
With recurring segments about stupid
YouTube comments or emails. It seems
to me that David is forgetting a cardinal
rule of interacting online. Don't feed the
trolls. Don't let them know that their
idiotic waffle bothers you. Don't engage
at all when you read out the ridiculous
nonsense and complain about the grammar
you're signaling they can reach you
and it affects you enough to feature.
In the show.
Don't overexplain. You don't need to
preempt criticisms like you just want
war with Russia or you're a communist.
Adapting your viewpoint points to
anticipate the B.S. only encourages
more with affection from a longtime
viewer. Ignore the wingnuts. Don't
give them any time or consideration.
End of rant.
Yeah. I mean, listen, I don't agree
with this 100%. I agree with it 90%.
That's why when we do the Friday.
Feedback segment or whatever,
it's just we feature a small sample of
the unhinged attacks and mostly to try.
To focus on productive discussions.
I do think that if we pretend that
they don't exist, we fall into.
An echo chamber, and I don't think
that that's good. So I think.
They should be featured in a limited
manner, handled appropriately.
And in that sense, I think
it's productive and a healthy.
Thing rather than creating
yet another echo chamber.
All right. Send in your thoughts info at
David Pakman dot com. Leave a YouTube comment,
post a tweet, whatever might be featured
here. Make sure that you're signed up to
the YouTube channel YouTube.com slash
The David Pakman Show and remember to
sign up for a membership at join
Packman dot com. It's the number
one funding source for The David
Pakman Show. Join Pacman dot com.
Coupon code please. No more
Trump. That's the code.
Please, no more trouble. I'll
see you on the bone, Chef.